what would he want with cocaine
hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
the king of late night Greg Gutfeld
continues to crush it was this more
fodder for the Republican machine
conspiracy no matter what the the answer
would have been there they were always
going to blame a hunter Biden they are
weaponizing Hunter Biden against his dad
as an effective tool to get his dad to
lose his cool and to get his dad to you
know feel the heartache and those people
who might believe that it was planted
for somebody so that then they could
Advance the hunter Biden narrative yeah
did you catch that according to that
lady
somebody planted the cocaine to frame
Hunter
because you know what would he want with
cocaine
yeah if there were only if there were
photographic evidence of Hunter's drug
use
no
maybe then we could believe that coke
belonged to him huh
yeah seeing the ladies of the view try
and use deductive reasoning is like
watching Bears try to do geometry
in fact I think the view should get
their own NBC series Law and Order
special units
[Applause]
[Music]